hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in part three of his treatise on the
basis of morality arthur schopenhauer is
going to finish up chapter 17 which is
all about the virtue of justice with a
very interesting
and well worked out discussion of the
morality
of lying and schopenhauer
is opposing his own position
to that of emmanuel kant in particular
saying for example that the
unconditional and boundless abhorrence
of lies which contivances on every
occasion
is due either to affectation
or
prejudice in the chapter of his doctrine
of virtue that deals with lies he
invades against them with every
defamatory epithet
but does not quote a single adequate
reason
for their condemnation which after all
would have been
more effective declamation is easier
than demonstration and moralizing easier
than being sincere and he says god could
have taken a different path
he would have done better to launch his
special indignation against the
malicious joy at the misfortune of
others this
not lying is really the
devilish
vice and then he talks about the
principle of nightly honor which he
thinks is kind of lurking behind the
scenes for kant the reproach of being a
liar is regarded as extremely grave and
really to be washed out with the
accuser's blood this is not because the
lie is wrong for them the accusation of
wrongdoing through violence would
inevitably just as gravely offensive we
know this is not the case on the
contrary it is because according to the
principle of nightly honor right is
really based on
might and so you know on the one hand
we've got kant whose views on lying are
not as good as they ought to be on the
other hand we have you know nightly
honor which is all just you know
tomfoolery and really needs to be gotten
past
but
not all lying is okay
what's wrong with lying
well if we back up a little bit he
begins by talking about cunning
and he says that
there's two
ways of doing wrong those violence to
other people and those of cunning so
through violence i can kill another
person
i can rob him i can force him to obey me
and he says by cunning i can do all
these things as well
and the lie
is a means to do that as a matter of
fact the means you could say par
excellence
i confront he says his intellect with
false motives in consequence of which
he must do what he otherwise would not
this is affected by means of the lie
whose objectionable nature rests on this
alone and therefore sticks to it only
insofar as it is an instrument of
cunning that is of compulsion by means
of motivation so with a lie you can kill
somebody you can force them you can rob
them you can do a lot more because
you're putting wrong ideas into their
head you're supplying them with
falsehoods instead of truth
in things that you know could be very
trivial or could be momentum so if you
think about how advertising works by
getting you to think that you should buy
a product that you don't really need
either they're engaging in cunning
they're lying to you and if you waste a
lot of money here's a great example
think about the advertisements that you
see
for online betting or for cryptocurrency
you better get in on it or else you're
going to lose out
well these are effectively lies right
and these are putting ideas into
people's heads and then they act on
those ideas they make decisions based on
those ideas they don't do other things
based on those ideas like keep their
money in the bank and not spend it on
frivolous things right so you're
confronting the intellect of another
person with false motives
is this by itself
automatically
wrong or bad
well this is where we have to ask what
is the motive lying behind a lie every
lie
works on the motives of other people but
every lie emerges from a motive that i
the liar
have for telling the lie and typically
these are going to be unjust i want to
get some sort of advantage over somebody
else i don't want them to compete with
me
for a job for a mate for a place to live
so i tell them lies about these things
or i lie to them about their own
capacities or whether there is a job
well that would be unjust
and
schropenhauer actually goes through a
number of different
clarifications here that are quite
important
so he says
this intention to compel other people by
means of motivation
underlies even the merely bombastic lie
what is a bombastic lie it's a lie where
you're saying something that like makes
you look better or
gets you into a group or something like
that and it's not really doing much of
anything
but there is a motivation what is the
motivation to raise yourself in the eyes
of others probably
not just higher than you deserve but at
the expense of others the person who
hears somebody else telling their travel
story and then they make up some other
travel story that sounds even cooler
right or you're talking about
celebrities and you make up a lie about
a celebrity so that you
get listened to that would be a
bombastic lie and you know it might not
be
in some sense as bad as a lie that leads
to somebody killing another person or
taking poison but you know it's it's
still a lie
and it's not for a good purpose
right it's raising oneself and others
eyes um he goes on with something much
more serious
and he talks about lying promises and
contracts you know kant brought this up
in the groundwork for the metaphysics
and morals in this very context saying
if i
know i need money
and i don't think i'll ever be able to
pay it back
is it okay for me to go to somebody
and ask them for a loan making a lying
promise that i will pay them back
and kant of course says no you can't do
that because you can't universalize this
truth and falsity itself would fall
apart schopenhauer says
you can't do that well you can do that
but you are doing wrong doing injustice
by doing that your motivation is wrong
and people see that and view it as a
kind of
treachery right the height of fraud and
what is going on when you do this
you want the other person to do
something that you're agreeing to
because a contract goes both ways right
you don't want to do your part
so
you
get them to do their part first and then
you
take off or you say i didn't really mean
it or something along those lines people
do this all the time right people make
lying promises
in part because they want to get
something
in the present and they don't want
ultimately to deliver
on what it is that they have committed
to so that that's an unjust
motive for lying so it seems like lies
are generally unjust right
well
yes
but schopenhauer thinks
that there are in fact many cases where
we
not only
can lie it's morally permissible for us
to lie but
we should lie it's
justice it's the right thing to do
and so he uses as an example of this um
self-defense
and he says that if you're allowed to
use violence against another
to protect yourself or perhaps to
protect other vulnerable others that the
aggressor is attacking and you can
justly use
self-defense to do that
then you can also do that with cunning
he says if i can repel force by force
without doing wrong and thus with right
so i can repel force with cunning if i
lack the power
or
if it appears more convenient to me
it's okay
to lie against an aggressor
even if you could resist them even if
you have the strength the arms and he
says in cases where i have a right to
use force i have a right to tell lies
for example i can resort to lies against
robbers and ruffians of every sort who i
can accordingly entice into a trap
through cunning right or you could lie
to him and say i've got a gun i'm going
to shoot you if you don't get out of my
house my apartment my trailer whatever
it happens to be right oh i've got i've
got a big dog that i'm going to release
and he'll bite your face off
you don't have a dog at all maybe of a
hamster instead right
who's not going to do anything
schopenhauer would say that's perfectly
fine to lie in those sorts of cases
he also says
a promise extorted by force is not
binding a robber comes in and says you
have to count to a thousand uh after i
leave and you say sure sure i'll do that
you don't have to count to a thousand
you have to count to anything you've
made a promise under
duress
and so he says the right to tell lies
goes even
further so this is very interesting
it occurs in the case of every and this
is an important qualifier wholly
unauthorized question
concerning my personal
or my business affairs which is prompted
by curiosity
if somebody wants to know things they
don't have a right to that information
and they're actually in many cases
transgressing
by asking for it this is a i think a
great point
you
were often made to feel as if we have to
give our information to other people
schweppenhauer is saying you don't know
you don't actually owe most people
anything
you don't have to give them that
information
at all
it's up to you he says if i should be
exposed to danger by answering it or
even by putting off an incurring
suspicion by saying i won't tell you
the lie becomes the legitimate means of
defense against unauthorized
inquisitiveness and now here's the key
thing
whose motive
he says
is hardly ever benevolent it could be
that the person who's asking you is just
trying to make conversation they're
being nice maybe they actually want to
invite you to a party they're asking
about
what's your schedule usually like
those could be benevolent
but you don't know because according to
schopenhauer most people are primarily
driven by
immoral anti-moral motives rather than
those of morality so responding to
unauthorized questions you have the
right to say i'm not going to tell you a
damn thing or you don't get to ask that
sort of thing or that's none of your
business he says i have the right to
oppose the implied bad will of others
so as a preventative mother measure i
can
repel them as i would some sort of
invader and he says without doing wrong
i can cunningly oppose in advance it
doesn't even have to be like on the spot
in advance
even the merely presumed harm through
cunning i don't have to give an account
to anyone who unwarrantedly
pries into my private affairs i don't
even have to say that there's a secret
involved right because by answering i
wish to keep this a secret i'm i'm
signaling that there's something that
i'm concealing from them and he says i
don't have to show him the place where
there's a secret that's dangerous to me
and possibly advantageous to him but
which any case puts me into his power on
the contrary
i am entitled to put him off of the lie
at his risk the lie is in this case
confronting the intellect of another
with false motives right and so you know
they ask me what's your schedule like
i'm having a party and you're like well
i'm very busy even though you're not
you'd rather just stay at home and watch
tv or something like that
they don't invite you and maybe you know
you would have been a good
speaker there or conversationalist or
whatever they lose out on it
too bad
they didn't have
any good reason to be expecting you
to tell them the truth and he's got this
wonderful
discussion here about the english
he says the english consider the
reproach of telling lies the gravest
insult right so they think telling lies
is very bad
and therefore
actually tell fewer lies than do other
nations okay that makes sense
accordingly
they regard as a piece of impertinence
and ill-breeding all
unauthorized questions concerning other
people's affair this is denoted by the
expression to ask questions
and he says you know ask me no questions
i'll tell you no lies because if you ask
me questions and you don't have a right
to that information
i get to tell you lies right so be fair
warned and he also talks about besides
self-defense other situations where
lies would be warranted or even a duty
and he brings up doctors
this is something i should point out
that has been changing in biomedical
ethics over the last maybe 50 years or
so
but in the past
the
interpretation of the hippocratic oath
that you know says that you shouldn't
harm patients it's you know a little bit
more complicated than that when you
actually look at the real oath itself
giving information
could be viewed as harmful to a person
because you're upsetting them about
something that they really can't do much
about so think about if you determine
that a patient has cancer
and there's no way of saving them
now actually i would say well you should
inform them so they can get their
affairs in order but the the tendency of
the past is to say oh no no don't upset
them just let them die
and
let them think that they're you know
just
not doing well but perhaps could get
better and then they'll die and it's
it's all over they didn't suffer quite
as much so that's one possibility
he also talks about magnanimous lies
and here what he seems to have in mind
is lying about whether you did something
to take on
the
punishment
that another person would have incurred
because they actually did it so
covering
for somebody else and taking on that
punishment would be
an example right
he brings up campanella
saying
it's fine to tell lies when they result
in so much good he also does bring up
the theory of the white lie and he calls
it the wretched patch on the garment of
miserable morality so he's not
countenancing every sort of white lie as
we call them lies with good consequences
lies to save other people's feelings or
things like that he does seem to think
that there has to be some good reason
to lie but schopenhauer is saying that
not all lies are
unjust as a matter of fact you might
have a duty in some cases to tell lies
whether to protect yourself or to
protect others from injustice from harm
and and violence and things like that so
lying is kind of a
complicated issue for schopenhauer
significantly more complicated than it
is for the people who he's criticizing
like emanuel kant
you